I begin with Heaven and Hell as states
of consciousness and reflections of the
kind of world that we're creating right
now so when people say war is hell
they're essentially saying it is a
dimension or an ax cumin seed --scent of
anything good peaceful generous
redemptive so the idea that an has
animated a lot of religion for a lot of
people that there is some divine beam
somewhere who if you don't say or do or
pray or think the right or believe the
right thing is going to send you to hell
life is difficult enough without
believing that the deepest strongest
forces of the universe are against you
and are going to torture you forever one
of the things I found most interesting
is that Jesus used the word hell but
when he used the word hell he was
referring to an actual place in the city
of Jerusalem in the first century the
word he used was the word Gehenna and
Gehenna means a valley of hinnom and the
Valley of Hinnom was the South Valley on
the south wall the city of Jerusalem
that's where people tossed their trash
so he's pretty much the only person who
used it and when he used this word he
was referring to a real place where this
trash was burning so essentially he was
saying you as a human being you have
this power to make choices about whether
you will move towards others in grace
and compassion and kindness or you will
move towards people in violence and
degradation and when you do that when
you mistreat others when you are
indifferent to their suffering you are
you're essentially a creating a Gehenna
on earth and so you're creating a hell
on earth so I begin with these as very
powerful words and pictures of what we
as human beings can create right now and
when you talk about that apparently for
a lot of religious people being right
isn't enough it's being right and other
people being wrong it's being in
other people being out it's being part
of the chosen and other people not being
part of the chosen for many people going
back to why spirituality has been so
sort of corrupted for so many people for
many people their fundamental
understanding of the spiritual life was
figuring out who's got it who doesn't
who's in who's out and I I begin with a
much more inclusive love for everybody
but then we can right now choose to live
particular ways in this world it's
really interesting like if you look at
the Bible which for many people in the
Western world was sort of the guiding
the Old Testament there isn't really any
sort of view of the afterlife the
closest you get is a word for pit a word
for abyss which basically means you die
and you're not here so this idea that
the whole thing is about when you die is
not really the way that lots of people
have thought about it and that the
phrase eternal life was a very first
century Jewish way of talking about
living in harmony with the divine right
now so eternal life wasn't a kind of
life that happens when you die eternal
life was understood to be a certain
quality of life that you're experiencing
right now where you're in right
relationship with the earth with the
environment with each other with
yourself that was considered eternal
life so I think we should start here I
think this is where the action is
you